[Inaudible]
ah, so-so
demo. Ah,
[inaudible].
Well, it's popping guys a little bit sick today, but it's okay.
I got sick from Montreal.
Uh.
Whatever, but, uh, I'm okay. Now just a little bit of cough, you know,
in case you care. But yet today we are moving, as you can see,
my room is sleep packed and now we hired some people to move
for us. So, yeah, I'll talk to you later. Uh,
I think I might code later on today, but for now I'm just gonna move and uh,
I'll show you some footage from that.
[Inaudible] take a little break.
Almost done packing. It's pretty good. Just gonna take a nap here.
Real quick. Alright. Pizza guys
was nice knowing you bumped that, but I think it's time to go.
[inaudible] I'm going to miss you. I've never felt that way for anyone else.
I love you from the bottom of my heart.
It's time for me to move on. It's time for you to move on to
always be my favorite bed frame.
It's kind of dirty though.
All right. What's up guys. So welcome to my new place. Now.
I don't want to show you everything yet because I want to keep it as a surprise,
make another video about it also haven't decorated yet, so, okay.
I'll wait until I'm done. But today we are doing some coding.
We didn't continue on our, on our web app. If you haven't seen the first video,
which was like some JavaScript title that I put I'll put in the link in the
description,
but you could check that out first and then I'll continue doing my web app
today, but that's cool. Oh yeah. Before I start,
I just wanted to tell you that the video that I'm putting here as a template is
that it's done by someone I really admire his name is [inaudible] and
he makes awesome cinematography videos. And uh, yeah,
I just want to shout him out, go check his channel, uh,
link in the description below.
He makes amazing videos and I aspire to become like him. Yeah.
Check them out. All right. Cool. So let's start, uh,
let's pull up the stuff that I had before. Okay, cool.
So,
so what I want to do now is I want to add socket IO because that's how I'm going
to communicate with the server. So what I'm going to do,
I'm just going to go to socket.io. Now socket.io is pretty cool.
It's basically like a,
like a library that wraps around the web socket technology.
If you don't know what web sockets are,
it's basically just a ongoing TCP connection from the client and the
server, like instead of HTTPS,
where it has to open a whole TCP connection. Every time it sends a request,
this one keeps it TCP connection and it will send back and forth.
So basically the advantage of that is that the server can push information
rather than the client having to request information from the server every time.
So instead of doing a polling mechanism,
the server can just push information to the client.
So if you don't know what TCP is, don't worry about it.
You'll learn it at school. It's like a basic network thing. So,
yeah. All right. Let's see. Okay.
Now the first thing I'll do read a little bit of docs.
Okay.
Yeah. So first of all, got it.
Install socket IO. Okay.
It's copied us.
Number.
Done. All right. Okay. Check it out.
Save it in package us Jason that's C socket. All right, cool.
I have it version two point. Oh, that's good.
So I have to change the server code a little bit because
right now is just express and basically I have to add socket IO.
So let me do that real quick. Do a little bit of a change.
Okay. Take this off and then, okay.
Perfect. All right. So I have this.
Perfect. And now I'm got to add the.
Addie IO, which is the library,
the athlete HTTP library.
Okay.
Let me just copy this.
All right. Now we are going to add the same thing, but their front end. Um,
I'm going to have to download the socket IO JavaScript.
Oh.
Okay. Finally I found the down button. There it is. Okay, cool.
So let's see how we do to fund that. Let me weakness.
Did you do up there?
Okay. All right. So another thing for you guys, for some people who are like,
Oh my God, man, you keep searching up. Oh my God, dude, what you know,
can't you don't you know about heart and stuff like that. Yeah.
So I just want to tell you, uh, if you don't like me searching things,
because I'm just trying to be realistic here. You know,
I just want to show you how I code, you know, I might not be the best colder.
So if you don't like it,
you can go find another YouTuber that would teach you web sockets.
So just saying, all right, anyways,
so I'm going to copy this code snippet.
I'll get a copy of this code snippet, uh, added to the front end.
All right. Frank code done. That's cool.
So we got WebSockets on dope. So now, uh,
I am just going to use that web socket and put events on the clicking on
the play,
clicking on the paws and clicking on the timeline so that we can send these
events back to the server using the web sockets.
So I'm going to do that right now.
[Inaudible].
All right, cool. So here we go. Now,
every time I press play, it's sensitive to the server. As you can see it,
press play every time I press pause, it says, pause.
Pause, play, pause, play, pause, play.
So as you can see, when I click the progress bar, I get the number basically.
Um,
this is like how many minutes or how many seconds into the video I'm clicking
to. So if it's at the beginning, it's like zero. And then if I click at the end,
it's like 47. So 47 seconds. All right, there you go.
So now the player is connected to the server, so that's cool.
Um, so I'm done for now. Uh,
I'm not going to do anything more because it's already been five, 10 minutes.
So I hope you liked that. And I'm going to continue doing this on each blog.
You know, maybe whenever I want to code and stuff, hope you liked this video.
If you enjoyed it,
don't forget to smash that like button and also subscribe and press the bell
notification. So thanks.
[Inaudible].